Web Accessibility Perspectives.
Text-to-speech.
A man is using a laptop with the text on the screen being highlighted as it is spoken.
Some people can see the text on the screen.
Fortunately, computers can convert text-to-speech.
It's technology that many people who are blind have been relying on for years.
A service dog is next to the man. He may be blind.
But it's also important for many people with dyslexia.
A woman is reading on a tablet and listening with headphones.
And very useful for people with difficulty reading text.
A man removes his glasses and listens to a news article on a tablet.
As well as some people who just like to multitask.
A man listens to a magazine article as they do the washing.
But for this to work, websites and apps have to be properly coded.
A website is not properly working for the woman with headphones. She is frustrated.
Which has the added benefit of helping search engines index websites' contents better.
The man with the service dog is using his mobile device outside with bone conduction headphones.
Different people from earlier are shown using text-to-speech.
Web Accessibility.
Essential for some.
Useful for all.
Visit w3.org slash wai slash perspectives for more information on text-to-speech.
W3C Web Accessibility Initiative. Copyright 2016.